You've now seen two loops, the while loop and the for loop. And now, you have
choices and which loop to take, and choices aren't always easy. So, let's look
at a typical problem. Let's say we have $10,000, and we get 10% interest. And
we want to know what happens to our nest egg over a period of 30 years. Which
loop should we take? Now, in this case, what's going to drive our decision is
the fact that we know we want to do something 30 times. And when you know how
often you want to do it, then the for loop is what you want to choose. Over
here, I've modified our program to do this. Here you see now I've changed the
balance to 10,000. I've changed the interest rate to 10%. And I have now that I
want 30 years. And then, I just write my loop here, where the year goes from
one to the numberOfYears, gets incremented every time. And inside here, you
have the familiar computation of the interest. So, notice that in this loop, I
know exactly how many times the loop is going to execute, namely, this many
times, 30 times. Let me run the program. Here you see the output. You see the
interest, and starting at 1, scrolled off at the top, and it went 30 times.
That's the classic case for the for loop. Contrast that with, the example of,
the first program that we had, where we wanted to become a millionaire. At that
point, we used a while loop, because we did not know how many years it was
going to take for us to achieve our lofty goal. When you don't know how many
iterations you want, the while loop tends to be the better choice. So, that
simply is your criterion for decision. Do you know how many times the loop
runs? You usually choose a for loop. If you don't know, you usually choose a
while loop.